I had the half the baby in my hand hold
on to me just because this is a
continuation of the original goat story
look here can I let me just show you
here just okay you're the goat okay let
me just go say you're the goat and so
just kind of move so I'm here I'm here
and I'm trying I'm trying to get the
baby punch I punched the bone in the
face huh but the goal whips around and
bites me in like this go fit me on my
face now you [ __ ] but the baby
goat is here and I grab the baby
because I go hey and then wait hard and
then I take a [ __ ] Rock hold on no
you call a baby go Dewey no look up what
they call it baby go stay there
pause in the story the [ __ ] up branch
tsunami nope what are you called baby go
you want to say it yeah Billy kid Billy
Billy a kid I kid but there can only be
one kid right brother
yeah so chill the [ __ ] up [ __ ] from
Raqqa
- this brain you cry
and I tried the Blair I put the blood on
my hair and that was the day I got fired
from MADtv but I became a Satanist I
gotta see although oh sorry dude that's
the real ghost story oh yeah so that's
the real good story dude thank you for
playing goat yes that was a good guys
goat in scene was a good dying go thank
you sir
so that's way better yeah but people get
mad when you kill a baby goat in front
of its mom and then you kill the goat
mistake ball silly the kid they call it
baby goat they call a baby Kota kid why
so when you eat baby goat when when you
see a restaurant they go we've got a
special as a kid is kid and I go well
there's only one kid and I'm not missing
any me yeah you can't have two kids that
can be only one you kill all dotes if
you see them so how the baby goat sir
you know you call it baby don't you kid
they are a cute they're adorable
I felt bad boys way better I felt bad -
bully reining yourself don't ever take
my back like that again saw what I do
yeah did you see my protection though
that's very good yeah I think choking me
no I was trying to have you bite my face
I don't know why you me Justin get
veneers I don't understand that we look
because I'm cool because after this
Invisalign and ten weeks dude I'm gonna
be a badass good looking at it you know
what you're doing you're [ __ ] up
Invisalign stock because you're gonna do
it you talked about in there and that's
not working I everyone else in your
[ __ ] [ __ ] I just went the DES and he
goes he goes you're a fang on yeah
exactly other words I'm moving in the
right direction to this [ __ ] my
teeth are moving in the right direction
no I can see from here they're no better
say [ __ ] their bed no they're not no
they're not and you know you're right
behind me with the Invisalign eventually
because I'm looking at your teeth I'm
getting onion veneers bro bro I'm going
veneers and here's a problem Chompy
white teeth I don't know sittin ears
don't they do you can tell people are
wearing veneers yeah and they look sick
they don't oh yeah oh you like shiny
[ __ ] and I know you want your teeth to
match those terrible boots that you
bought with the buckle that you never
wear anymore they're sitting in your
date no one Mun setta below the belt
those my favorite boots don't wear it
doesn't so my faves
don't say fave those my days if you were
I wish you weren't as tough as you were
cuz I'd have to think about it I'd slap
your mouth
dude I'll tell you get on TRT I'll get
veneers I'm not I don't need it I don't
need trt I'm finally calming down I'm
finally like all right I'm not I'm
finally not jacking off all day it was
gorgeous man it's it's it's not any of
your house there yeah you be neighbors
there yeah I'd love that I'd love that I
won't be the same we won't be any
happier I don't know you have that view
I know you get you standing I did a
podcast with Bert Kreischer on Friday
I'm not sure when he releases about how
I'm never happy and how he isn't either
that's that's there that's that's the
human condition always wanting going
from one to one but I'm obsessed now at
51 with the idea that there's a way out
of that yeah you'd be wrong oh yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah he's Garry Shandling
meditated day for said day I'm like the
happiest clam here
who else you want to go with Conan
O'Brien [ __ ] happy man why is Conan
not he talks about it just like you know
like everyone thinks he thought his
dream job was gonna be oh saying it's a
dream job because sometimes it's a
[ __ ] night of course it is it and I
don't want to do it of course you know
it's always you know what you want when
you finally get it I'm sorry but there
are this you know this and everybody
knows this that that's saying finally
the hottest girl in a while finding you
guys tired of [ __ ] her there there
are women that are just you're like wow
you're incredible and I don't want to
bang well it's weird it's like that when
you find out what celebrities was like
he cheated on her and P Reich what how
could you cheat on put whatever girl you
want and then I think some guys I know
yeah makes sense yeah not that you
wouldn't want to hook up with his shirt
that you get the house sure if you
listen I love human beings but every
goddamn morning yeah how many switching
up that's right I love humans they get
used to everything everything you get
[ __ ] used on that story that you told
me that one don't you not say any names
for that time when you were
you were rolling yeah and then he
invented kinda said watch this and gave
you got a little yeah if you're a giant
guy you don't want to you don't want to
go you don't wanna be disrespectful and
do this this is what you don't want to
do with Brendan when he's wrong if you
roll with Brendan I've seen him do it
with with really good guys Brennan is
such a [ __ ] gentle giant he's not
gonna he's not trying to tap you're not
trying to win we're rolling right but
don't do this job you know don't beat up
my friend in front of me and your old
friend just trying to be cool actor
friend who's a blue belt used to be you
do that
yeah cuz then Brendan Brendan can I go
you can't that's a proxy he gets that's
where he's tribal that's where he's like
that's my boy now I got a punish you so
then you see him kind of turn it on you
know and by the way he's not really
turning it on he's just upping it to
seven where he could go ten but he might
happen to say so you know the because
people thinking in in movies when you
fire guys they're not they're not hands
high and tucked right form like that's
not Cano and that bothers me right now
that I bought it's it's so even in photo
shoots I remember in photo shoots that's
the first when I was shooting for the
UFC or shooting for a sponsor you know
they might throw a straight right and
you like this like we're gonna put your
hand on like well no I'm not gonna throw
it right like we need it for the picture
I think well that's wrong right so the
in pictures you see guys like this right
that's why did I show you guys the video
I'll show you guys after yeah you know
thing so yeah again you know it was we
had this big fight scene and it you know
he's a hero
rocky what's the movie called escape
plan it's coming out soon yeah it comes
out in the next Whitstable month is it
me June comes on that in the next movie
yeah thank you for the but so I was
nervous again about the fight scene yeah
I mean you know I've watched this guy my
whole life he's had the greatest fight
scenes in movies and and so I was really
nervous about it but then I was you know
I was like you know I get to show him
like you know my hands gonna be tucked
on you know yeah and an afternoon
and he and he really showed me movie
fighting and it's come I mean you come
down from here what you're about to
touch the floor yeah yeah it comes back
at that and as we're doing I'm like
everybody's doing the thing I don't know
it's gonna look terrible although
sometimes they do sweet sometimes like
everything we watch it cut and it's like
man this is this is why he's got a PhD
and he ended by HD in movie movie for me
he explains like he knew with the camera
because the camera was circling around
and he's like just timing punches with
the camera is I'm blocking the view so
when it comes the when the cameras
behind me and that comes across you know
it's too far away from the face and it
doesn't see it but it catches the
reaction as it comes around and he you
know Cory grabs really he's a really
really smart guy yeah really and then we
saw the gunman we saw a cut together and
I was like holy Sh good stop man no
other cameras he directed to impedance
ain't no Steven Miller phenomenal
director directed it but he when it
can't and we had some great stunt
coordinators there but when it came
nobody knows more about movie fighting
they're gonna little own yeah so he kind
of came in saw what we were gonna do and
then he put his stamp on do you have to
audition for mr. slow no hmm every
silver do failed inside of tests they
don't they're not saying what it is yet
though that's a fighter's face right
there boy mmm love love for doom bit of
a bummer let's not let's not put them
over the coals yet let's wait to see the
full story would you sign up there's so
[ __ ] picky and we've seen guys who
could just [ __ ] throw him to the
wolves and then they're screwed and then
can you really hear CBD with USANA
yeah this yeah now they are but with
Verdi me I'll see what was yeah there's
been nothing new right what he did or
what he said it's gonna be tough if he
goes out was the talk goes or that or
you know there's a protein powder it's
gonna be tough but let's not just be
like oh he's [ __ ] let's see what
happens actually yeah it's all from
yesterday so yeah yeah let's wait and
see the full hoodie comes and goes after
everybody he's just not those who
actually have an issue they do yeah yeah
Oh cuz I included boomerang
his cookery cut he was talking about
Colby was talking about Brazil yeah they
got a fight down Brazil beat his ass
with me yeah it's not the point they'll
be never real like animosity towards
each other
this is what he does the trolls everyone
non-stop fryer you do the time you
filthy animal it's hilarious ham I know
it is funny you got title shot because
of this so I don't yet Jim all right so
the UFC is going to ESPN for their TV
deal as well five-year deal huge this is
so big mmm this is a huge deal because
everyone was freaking out because I
thinking you with Fox what's gonna
happen yeah and people are making for
the UFC cuz they did the the digital
deal with the ESPN Plus and you know
this is it it could have got gone any
better for the year see being on ESPN
yeah I mean it's a billion-dollar deal
it's not the amount they were looking
for but today I'm close my thing is does
it does this say how many paper use
they're gonna do it says thirty UFC
finites
TV shows on ESPN that's a lot on
nevermind 10 main cards on ESPN TV and
24 ESPN Plus so 30 total so it's 30 so
that pull it then you're gonna get then
so 10 UFC still gonna do their paper
paper be a separate yeah yeah now
hopefully they don't continue to do as
many paper views
mmm that's my only wish and I think
that's what they're gonna get rid of the
Ultimate Fighter and they're just gonna
highlight Dana White's looking for a
fight like two home run its home run for
Fox 2 everyone's like Oh Fox and me
screwed no Fox has 30 W they paid
something like three billion dollar debt
to me that's just a bigger fan base it
works out for everyone
and now ESPN can learn about Fox did
wrong and make it better let's say it's
ESPN if you want to be mainstream ESPN
yeah that's the biggest one by four it's
Disney it's [ __ ] Disney cockfighting
is now on Disney